a lot of times you do stuff and then
until years later that you figured out
what hold needs though actual plot movie
is a robot baby in his machine when
scanning the robot porn web for you know
any kind of robot sex things you can see
the robot movie started out it was going
to be a robot war between you know
analog and digital robots you know it's
going to be you know all violence all
the time just goofing around
you know I am there a robot sex scene
and that seemed really funny so it can't
turn my mind around to do there's a
couple of robots it's so exciting
because it fuses so many different
creative levels he has his his
sculptural pieces and then he has a stop
animation that really brings them to
life even though it's not very sexy it's
technically a porno phone because of the
you know penis and vagina you know you
know which is all over the place I think
those people himself they're sculpted
and they're beautiful and then he's
really taking this concept of you know
the sex lives of robots and how would
they procreate and how would this the
sexuality occur in these creatures that
are somewhat human life that are not and
that really that the film and the humor
and the art of it
in a way it's the kind of film that
anybody could do and it stemmed from
what kids do normally you know playing
with dolls and playing with little
action figures you know for the robot
movie almost all the models are made out
of Barbies or GI Joes or things that are
already articulated and I sometimes have
put you know bolts to them to make them
stiffer sex life a robust teaser was
thrown together on a Mac to show the sex
museum you know to try to interest them
in an exhibit you know it used to be on
YouTube for like a year and I got 27,000
hits in a couple of days and somebody's
mom complained you know because they
didn't want their kid watching you know
some robot stick his dick in a horse's
but you know you know I would have
thought I'd be finished last year but
you know the deeper I get into it the
more complicated it gets and the more
ideas I get about what it should be and
where it's going and there's no pressure
to finish it you know except my own so
even though nobody's gonna you know be
getting their rocks off to this the the
limitations of a porno movie are still
you know you're still bound by that if
it turns out to be horrible little
this'll fade away and if it turns out to
be an ultra weird film it'll you know be
in the zeitgeist for a while
[Music]